you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme the uk's dirty
secret we report on the swamps of toxic
waste
the environment agency doesn't have a
record of
how climate change could be contributing
to the united states mega drought
and how cotton production is at risk
from global warming
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes
happening to our world right now and we
meet those developing
the solutions coming up the tuneful way
one company is persuading delivery
drivers to go green
but we start today with the story behind
the uk's acid
tar lagoons these toxic waste dumps are
environmental nightmares
but little is being done to clean them
up skies inzamam rasheed has the story
this is an acid tar lagoon a swamp
made up of 60 000 tons of toxic waste
from oil refineries near chester it's a
toxic
waste dump it's absolutely vile to be
around here there's nothing living in
there
anything that's close to being alive is
covered in
oil and tar for 60 years this pit of
poisonous gunge
has been blighting the lives of those
who live nearby
obviously i've got kids so the
environment for the health of the kids
it's obviously not great
being there it's literally a few hundred
yards down the road so
it's not great for anyone that lives in
this area at all according to the
environment agency
there are only two acid tar lagoons in
this
country for our investigation found
councils across the uk have officially
identified 34.
we took samples to see how dangerous
they really are
this is litmus which will indicate the
ph and as you can see
it goes uh to a bright red color
indicating a ph of one to two
so this is a highly acidic material for
a long time acetar lagoons have been a
hazard
to the natural environment controlled
waters
and in some instances human health they
now cost tens of millions of pounds to
clean up
and no one is taking responsibility
the environment agency told us the
identification of these sites
sits with local authorities however when
asked we will work collaboratively to
inspect the land to ensure risks to the
environment are understood
and the area remains safe acid lagoons
may have been around for more than half
a century
but little is known and being done about
our past actions
well if you want to see the full report
on the uk's acid
tar lagoons including the green solution
that's being used to help clean up one
site in
derbyshire then you can head over to our
youtube channel that's youtube.com
sky news well let's take a look at some
of the day's other climate news now
and moscow has been hit with a heat wave
temperatures reaching record-breaking
highs some parts of the city
saw temperatures hit 34.7 degrees
celsius
on monday that matches a record for a
day back in june
1901. scientists say that heat waves are
becoming more frequent
and more intense as global temperatures
rise
over time the un says the world's oceans
will continue to be destroyed if urgent
changes aren't made in the way that
they're managed
a report from the un environment
programme suggests 80 percent of marine
and coastal pollution
comes from land-based human activities
it's calling on governments to introduce
policies to reduce the effects that
these activities have
on coastal resources and to support the
transition
to a sustainable ocean-based economy
marine workers in taiwan have started
cleaning up an
oil spill off the country's southwest
coast
state-owned cpc corps said that the leak
occurred at its refinery in tallinn
on tuesday morning that's after bad
weather had caused a crack
in the pipeline it's hoped that the
prompt response by workers will minimize
the environmental impact caused by the
spill
more than half of teachers in england
want to encourage children to take
direct action against climate change
that's according to a new survey
research by the university of bristol
has found almost
all teachers believe in an
action-focused climate change curriculum
and 54 say that this should extend
to taking part in civil disobedience at
secondary school
and bird songs are being played on cargo
bikes across london
as part of a campaign to encourage
delivery drivers
to use low carbon transport 30 riders
have installed radios on their bikes to
play out the sounds of
gold finches blackbirds and bluetits
on all of their deliveries in july the
scheme aims to show people what cities
could sound like
if there were fewer cars and vans on the
road
to the united states now and president
biden has said that he'll bring
every resource to bear in dealing with
the severe drought and extreme heat
that's affecting the southwest
of the country the heat wave there has
broken hundreds of temperature records
increased the risk of wildfires and
affected water and electricity supplies
as well
and the country's biggest reservoir is
at record low
levels well we can show you here the
scale
of what is happening this is a map from
the u.s drought monitor from july
last year the lightest colors are no
drought
through to orange which shows you
moderate drought and the red color
shows extreme drought conditions but
this
is the picture this year in the west of
the united states you can see
vast swathes there the darkest red color
that shows exceptional drought as well
as far
more of the red extreme drought markings
well joining me now is professor
catherine hey ho chief scientist
at the nature conservancy in the united
states also
one of america's leading climate
scientists
professor hey ho good to talk to you
it's pretty drastic isn't it when you
see the difference of those
two maps there and this is before
the height of the summer
it absolutely is and of course we have
droughts and floods
naturally but what we are seeing is that
climate change is loading the weather
dice against
us making those droughts longer and
stronger than they would be otherwise
and also at the same time increasing our
heavy precipitation
and how do you explain scientifically
what is happening
as the world warms we know that it is
getting warmer and i know that sounds a
little bit obvious
but what that's doing is it's super
sizing our extreme heat waves here in
the united states extreme heat waves are
already three to five degrees fahrenheit
which is about um you know one and a
half to
almost three degrees celsius warmer than
they would be otherwise because of a
changing climate
so when a drought comes along that
drought and heat
reinforce each other building up a
stronger ridge that directs
us storm systems away from the region
leading to hotter and drier conditions
than we would ordinarily have it's been
long forewarned hasn't it by scientists
like you with your modelling have you
been surprised at how
quickly it's taken hold
it's no surprise what's happening but
the surprise is how quickly we are
seeing it happen with our own eyes in
the places where we live
today we can no longer say climate
change is a future issue
wherever we live here and now we are
seeing its effects
and they are affecting our lives it's
not only about the polar bears the ice
caps and sea level rise
it is literally about the food we eat
the air we breathe the water we drink
the safety of our homes we're looking at
incredibly high temperatures if this
kind of thing
continues do you see parts of the world
that effectively become
unlivable it would have to progress
considerably before we could see large
parts of the world that would become
unlivable
but that is possible if we don't heed
the warnings today
but these warnings are loud and clear
climate is changing and humans are
responsible we've known that for over a
hundred years
we also know now that the impacts are
here and now
but that there are solutions there truly
are solutions
that can wean us off our addiction to
fossil fuels that can help stabilize
climate
that can put carbon back into the soils
and the trees and the ecosystems where
we actually want the carbon
instead of up in the atmosphere where we
don't and that help us reduce our energy
use save money
and provide clean energy to the hundreds
of millions of people
who don't even have electricity today
there are
real solutions and those solutions are
good for us and that is an important
pairing with the risks professor
catherine hey ho
thank you very much thank you for having
me
now cotton makes up 31 of all the fiber
that's used in the textile industry
worldwide
and the sector directly supports the
livelihoods of
hundreds of millions of people but half
of all cotton growing regions
face severe climate risks by 2040 if
carbon emissions
continue to increase that's from the
first ever
global analysis of climate risks to the
industry
here's everything you need to know about
those findings in 60 seconds
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and there's some positive news to bring
you today and that's that nearly
two-thirds of wind and solar projects
built last year
will generate cheaper renewable energy
than the most competitive
fossil fuel option the international
renewable energy agency
says that the cost of renewable
technologies is falling
every year with onshore wind power 13
cheaper in 2020 than it was in 2019.
in less than a decade the cost of
large-scale solar power
has fallen by more than 85
and according to the director general of
irena renewables are now
the cheapest source of power
well here on our data dashboard you can
see the real time
power mix for electricity in great
britain today
currently you can see that 47
is coming from fossil fuels 35
from renewables and 18 from
nuclear well that is everything from us
for today on the daily climate show
tomorrow i'll be speaking to the founder
of the restaurant chain oaxaca
thomasina myers about how changing the
way we farm
could help to save the planet that's at
the same time tomorrow
here on sky news see you then